from calorical to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between wendy's and japan and the u.s
this is food wars
in japan our wendy's hamburgers come in
four sizes
junior single double and triple
in the u.s our brokers come in four
sizes junior dave single dave's double
and the dave's triple look at the size
of this thing
in japan our nuggets come in orders of 5
and 10.
our us nuggets come in 4
6 and 10 piece
our wendy's drinks come in three sizes
small medium and large
and in the us we also have three drink
sizes small medium you've got to be
kidding me look at the size of this
thing this might be 40 ounces julie only
one way to find out
oh
oh
not quite 40. about 36 or 37 fluid
ounces of coca-cola and how big is a
bladder this looks like more than like i
would normally pee in the morning okay
let's measure our large drink
it measures exactly
500 milliliters
our wendy's fries come in two sizes
small and medium
our fries come in four sizes junior
small
medium
large let's wear our largest
roughly 180 grams
he weighs
135 grams japan's chili comes in two
sizes medium and large
and the u.s our chili comes in two sizes
small and large
let us weigh the largest now
including the paper cup
430 grams let's weigh our large chili
265 grams
in japan avenis burger usa double is 730
yen or
6.38 centiways our us dave's double goes
for 5.99 or around 685 japanese yen
that's a 6.16 decrease in price in the
u.s let's make it a meal in japan if you
get your burger as i said it includes a
small fries and a three piece nuggets
and a drink it costs around 440 yen more
our meals only include fries and drink
so a small dave's double meal and i
threw in a four piece because we don't
have a three piece works out to 10.98
that's an 8.12 increase cost in the u.s
mind you we did get an extra nugget
speaking of nuggets in japan tempest
nugget is 500 yen which breaks down to
51 yen per nugget in the u.s a 10-piece
nugget is 429 which makes it per nugget
around 43 cents so per nugget average
the us is paying eight point eleven
percent less a bacon a double in japan
is 850 yen or seven dollars 43 cents a
width in the us you get that same
baconator for 7.49
or
857 japanese yen so close only a point
eight two percent increase
here is everything you can get at the
wendy's in japan you cannot get in the
us
and here's everything in the us wendy's
you can't get in japan
one thing i want to point out is that in
japan wendy's is known as wendy's first
kitchen first kitchen is a japanese fast
food chain and it was acquired by
wendy's in 2016 and became a hybrid of
wendy's and first kitchen's venues and
we call them
[ __ ]
which is the abbreviation of first
kitchen in a japanese way it's like
first kitchen safa and kitchen's kit and
and say [ __ ]
repeat after me [ __ ]
got it buddy
very good so here are our japan's
exclusive burgers so this one is bacon
mushroom melt
and this one is just mushroom melt we
have wendy's bacon neck burger
we also have wendy's cheese bacon egg
burger and this sauce
tatters us
everybody's curious what this is this
one is
wild rock
it's got no buns it's got two beef
patties i think i should try this one
this meat itself has a good taste and
some kind of like peppery flavor
but
it's a little bit dry i wouldn't get
this again
and last things we have junior teriyaki
burger and we have junior teriyaki
cheeseburger
the big bacon cheeseburger
the big bacon double
look at this yup one two three the big
bacon triple i mean i don't know what
what what angle
it's best to look at this at
and then we got big bacons on the fancy
bread this must be the big bacon's
classics's
this looks like
a big bacon looks like shredded cheese
and stuff on this everything's baking
something with these guys
at this point it's just like how many
slabs of meat do you want on your bacon
sandwich two things you can get at a
wendy's in the u.s cannot get in japan
or just the
junior burger and the junior
cheeseburger look at this look at this
little guy look at this literally every
fast food burger place has a version of
this
chicken
the asiago chicken sandwiches we got the
asiago chicken ranch classic club i said
that in the wrong order but you get what
i mean
probably this one this is the fried
asiago club with bacon and then there is
the
spicy which i'm assuming is this one
and then they got
the grilled
that's pretty good
don't like astiago
when this has you covered so many
chicken sandwiches at wendy's that of
course are not
asiagoed this is the grilled chicken
sandwich as you can see
it is grilled and then we have the
grilled chicken big bacon man they got
they must have gotten some deal on bacon
for wendy's everything's got bacon on it
i'm going to go ahead and assume this is
the big bacon fried chicken sandwich
because there's bacon on it
say the spicy big bacon cheddar chicken
in japan our brandies have pasta which
were originally on the first kitchen
menu so here we have ramen style soy
cream pasta with spinach and ham it
expires
2023
january 20th
joe i'll keep this for you
nah my guy you can go ahead and throw
that out
and next we have ramen style tan tongue
soup pasta with spinach and ham so tan
tan soup is kind of like a spicy chili
flavored soup with miso and pork mince
tantan soup and panta ramen are very
popular in japan tomato sauce pasta
with mozzarella
and bacon
all right next we have
beef chick white cream spaghetti
plastic
next we have carbonara spaghetti
carbonara carbonara
it's got bacon and this creamy
carbonara sauce
bin
last thing i have is spicy cardero
spaghetti so spicy cuadro
in japanese is men taiko and mentaiko
spaghetti is also very popular in japan
unfortunately some americans i know
don't like men taiko so much because of
the texture and smell but for me
mentaiko is super
[ __ ] delicious
uh it's been a while
since i got this one it's been like
three hours
um
joe
tried it out i appreciate the offer
george but you can go ahead and finish
that because it looks [ __ ] disgusting
we got salads over here on this end the
first one looks like we got the parmesan
caesar salad comes with of course caesar
dressing and what looks to be parmesan
crisps this next salad is ridiculous
we're going to go ahead and put quotes
around salad wendy's has a taco salad
that
comes with tortilla chips sour cream
signature salsa
and that wasn't enough chili
before we continue you confirm that the
taco salad is supposed to have chili on
it they told you that
chips all around here
i can't believe this this is so gross
signature salsa
then chili
oh it smells so bad
oh god
i'm just this is just like eating chili
with tortilla chips they said there's
some salt i'm just pushing this around
on to the next salad the southwest
avocado salad
oh my god there's bacon on it that's
weird that was in dave thomas's obituary
i want everything to be covered in bacon
but yeah chicken avocado bacon cheese
and some sauce this makes sense and the
last salad
apple pecan salad that smells oh cause
it's like a blue cheese on it roasted
pecan bits pomegranate vinaigrette
apples are nice it's kind of nice to get
a little bit of actual like fruit
something nutritious while doing this
it's like my body's like what is this
so here are our japan-style menu we have
a few flavor options for fries so we
have healthy butter flavored fries
happy butter flavor
it has just subtle buttery flavor
burnt butter soy sauce flavor
rip it off
i don't know what's going on here but
it's pretty good much better than this
savory steamed potato butter it gets
quite strong buttery flavor definitely i
prefer this one than the happy butter
flavor this is not happy
this one is
chicken consummate flavor
this is the best fries i've ever had in
my life now i'm gonna introduce you this
spicy
chicken
breast
wendy's in the u.s also has baked
potatoes see what we got of course
there's your
regular and this one oh yeah this one's
got like chives and stuff in it if i was
to stop here you would go wow what a
tasteful selection of healthy potatoes
but of course we don't stop here we move
on to absolute baked potato madness ah
number one
cheese baked potato drowned this thing
in cheese it's like it's like oh it's
like cake to the side ugh
[Music]
[Laughter]
the chili and cheese baked potato
if you are like me
you're wondering yourself
something's missing something
is missing
from this potato menu yuli can you guess
what that is the bacon cheese baked
potato oh i got big pieces of bacon this
one too
oh
you can get spicy chicken nuggets
yes siree bob
seasoned potatoes
all right so fruit finally made the menu
apple slices it wouldn't be a wendy's
category without
the baconator fries we need the bacon
meter in this episode last of the sides
oh yeah
oatmeal bar looks like a cloth bar
well it's actually pretty good
so here are our japan's exclusive drinks
we have tapioca royal milk tea with
brown sugar and tapioca milk with brown
sugar
tornado
[Music]
this is amazing
simply amazing i love this so here are
other drinks we have pepsi
orange juice
and ginger ale
lemonade and melon soda
peach tea and iced tea ice matcha and
this one is iced cocoa
so here we have our hot drinks
we have
darjeeling tea
and we have coffee mocha
and we have peach tea
[Music]
i like this and we have coffee latte
and cocoa
and
matcha this is matcha but it looks like
water from 100 years ago
our wendy's has frosty chinos which i'm
assuming are frosties meat frappuccinos
frosty chinos but it does not appear
that there's frosties in this
they have two flavors vanilla and
chocolate
i'm assuming this is the vanilla
wendy's are smart on this one it isn't
that it isn't that sweet i was expecting
it to be like undrinkable but it's
actually kind of nice all right this one
is the chocolate
yeah also
it's a nice flavor because the frosted
chinos you know what that means
a wendy's doing also good oh yeah
frosties they don't have these in japan
i feel like this is the staple menu item
i love these so much
fantastic that's fantastic that's
fantastic i got to go for the chocolate
don't buy the fundamental spoon i'm just
gonna do a taste there it's great the
froshes are great
it's like a milkshake but it's super
thick and delicious japan
you want this
thick it is thick
in japan we have floats instead of
frosties we have coke float and melon
soda float
japan has an exclusive breakfast
sandwich
it's called the breakfast sandwich
it's got tomato lettuce
and
i believe this is
beef or pork patties
okay whereas japan has one exclusive
breakfast sandwich we have way more like
all the fast food here in america we
take our breakfast very seriously you
can get yourself a maple
bacon croissant it looks like it's a
chicken sandwich that of course has
bacon and maple syrup on the croissant
uh we have what just appears to be the
bacon biscuit bacon
egg
cheese in the incredibly dry biscuits
bacon croissant i don't know about this
one moving on to the sausage zone
of the wendy's breakfast this is the
special sausage biscuit no no no no no
here's what i hate about this pick a
dryer thing to have for breakfast i feel
like it'd be impossible to swallow a
bite of this you're gonna choke on it
here we go see this is what i'm talking
about they might have gotten this
backwards this is actually the better
sausage one this at least has a better
chance of not getting stuck in your
throat the sausage croissant
also has egg thank you they have a few
things that are honey butter based i am
so glad that fast food places are
introducing honey to the breakfast menu
i think maybe it's to do with the fact
that chicken sandwiches have become so
popular first one we got here is the
honey butter biscuit
hey it's just a biscuit with honey
butter i mean yeah i'll have this
anytime i'll have this any time this one
has some heft to it it's the hot honey
biscuit yeah
a little chicken on there yep
i really like that
this is the special chicken croissants
so here are our desserts
so here we have melo totso so melotozo
are maritota style pastries which are
popular in rome and japan as well made
with melon bread so melon bread is a
type of sweet japanese bread which has a
sugar cookie crust on the surface but
what's funny is that it doesn't have a
melon flavor at all
at all the reason it's called melon
bread is that it just looks like melon
does it look like melon
it does in japan
and this time
first kitchen made of maritotto using
melon bread and mascarpone cheese
whipped cream and it's called melotozo
so here we have melotozo uh tiramisu and
melotozo matcha and melody plain so
actually yesterday was my birthday
february 18th hey it's your birthday
happy birthday george
thank you for your message thank you
arigato gozaimasu so this is my birthday
present
all right so let's give it a shot
best birthday present ever
itadakimasu
this is so good i can't stop eating this
so wendy's in japan has a japanese
traditional sweet since it has been a
collaboration with first kitchen so we
have shiratama cream sentai
so it has three main ingredients ice
cream and sweet red beans and the
shiratama which is kind of like a mochi
rice cake and my grandma likes this type
of zenzai
this is for you my grandma and also we
have
mini pancakes
in the u.s we only have two exclusive
desserts into both cookies that's no
disrespect to cookies cookies are great
but one of those fun like italian ice
cream sandwiches they have anyway you
get two cookies here in the u.s a
chocolate chunk cookie and a sugar
cookie
[Music]
our wendy's double burger is 578
calories and 29 of your daily
recommended amount and 60 of the
recommended daily sodium our double
burger the dave's double isn't much
better ours is 850 calories and way more
fat over 70 percent
but
less sodium just a bit over half of the
daily amount still
not great make the meal in japan and
that increases the calories to 1089
that's 55 of your daily recommended
calorie intake and if you make it a
combo here we chose the small and took a
few sips that's
440 more calories bringing the total to
1290
or
64.5 percent of your daily allowance in
japan the single menu item with the most
calories is the eight piece fried
chicken pack which contains
4018 calories
201 percent of your daily calories
in the us our single biggest calorie
menu item is the feed the fam deal a fam
yeah right this is all for you it is two
spicy chicken sandwiches two junior
bacon cheeseburgers and four a small
fries
total 2 780 calories which is
139 percent of your daily intake
japanese wendy's doesn't disclose their
ingredients list
why japan
the u.s sure does now is there anything
we should be looking out for
of course there is let's start with
sodium nitrate which is found in the
baconators applewood smoked bacon sodium
nitrate is a chemical that is used to
cure meats and gives meat that appealing
pink color perfect for bacon also get
this it's super toxic it is restricted
for purchase online people have
accidentally eaten too much of it and
died it's also been used in homicides
yikes sodium nitrate is on a list of
japan's designated food additives but
our wendy's gets its bacon imported from
denmark where it isn't bad but being
reduced in use
our american cheese contains lecithin
common emulsifier that according to one
academic a worrisome number of
scientific studies have suggested that
too much of it can promote depression
the pickles contain polysorbite 80 this
is commonly used as an emulsifier in
foods but pickles tend to be used as a
solubilizer not how that's pronounced
sorry which helps other ingredients in
the brine fully dissolve
studies have suggested it can cause
colon cancer in mice
not fantastic there is no info on when
this website of where the pickles come
from but we want to point out that
polysorbate 80 is on japan's list of
designated additives and therefore is
permitted to be used in japan
i want to try that